good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways that you
can find your passion number two is my
personal favorite but I'm curious to
find out which one you guys like the
most people say you have to have a lot
of passion for what you're doing and
it's totally true and the reason is is
because it's so hard that if you don't
any rational person would give up it's
really hard and you have to do it over a
sustained period of time so if you don't
love it if you're not having fun doing
it you don't really love it you're going
to give up and that's what happens to
most people actually if you really look
at the ones that ended up you know being
successful unquote in the eyes of
society and the ones that didn't
oftentimes it's the ones that are
successful love what they did so they
could persevere when you know when it
got really tough and and the ones that
didn't love it quit because they're
saying right who would want to put up
with this stuff if you don't love it so
it's a lot of hard work and and it's a
lot of worrying constantly and if you
don't love it
you're going to fail so you got to love
it you got to have passion
so there was a wonderful article by
Steven Kotler
published in Forbes about how to find
your passion it's a question we ask
ourselves every single day we've all
been told that a life of passion is a
life that means something but how do we
identify our passions it's not always
easy so one of the things that Steven
Kotler breaks down is that he says that
passion essentially exists in the
intersection between multiple things
that you're curious about so he says the
first thing you should do if you want to
identify your passion is to make a list
of all the things that you're curious
about all the things that you wonder
about be as specific as you can and then
create kind of a Venn diagram and try to
figure out where the things that you're
curious about three or more intersect
and that's the sweet spot that's where
there is energy that's where there is
dopamine and neurobiology multiple
streams of curiosity intersected a space
called passion right and then once
you've identified your passion then you
can figure out how to turn that passion
into a purpose turn that passion into a
purpose make a list of 15 things in the
world 15 challenges you'd like to see
solved and then figure out which one of
those challenges can be served by your
passion so then you see curiosity leads
to passion multiple streams of curiosity
leads to passion identifying problems in
the world that can be served by your
passion leads to purpose then my friends
even pregnat it your life with a sense
of significance with a sense of meaning
and then you can go forth my brothers
you can go for keep trying different
things it's okay to not know a hundred
percent what you're passionate about
it's not a crime to being a job that
you're not a hundred percent in love
with but there are things that you can
do alright don't be a victim that's the
thing that drives me crazy when I talk
to people and they like it but uh like
yo if you really want if you get to the
point where it's more uncomfortable
being where you are you will figure it
out
but a lot of times we get stuck in these
ruts we let other people's perception of
what they think we should do for
ourselves sort of decide what we do and
this is crazy it's absolutely nuts guys
life is way too short to be living
without passion and for a career if
you're in a place where you're does not
100% happy there is absolutely no better
time than right now to try and figure it
out because you're amazing and you
deserve it what area of your life do you
fear judgment in right is there an area
you have a backlog of work whether it's
songs or poems or any piece of art or
business or whatever it is that you're
afraid to share with other people for
fear of being judged this means that you
care about it tremendously it's core to
your identity and so you will work hard
to be excellent at it when I look back
at my own life writing was the clear
winner ever since I was kid I've been
writing I'd been taking creative writing
classes every chance I got but I was
very scared to publish in any sort of
school newspaper or blogger and anything
and that was because it was core to Who
I am
right if somebody didn't like my writing
I thought that would tear me apart of
course that's not the case but look for
that area what are those things that
you're afraid to share that means that
it is really important to you and you'll
work to be good at it don't fool
yourself and thinking you're getting
lots of energy back in your life if
you're constantly wiped out because
you're not sleeping enough you're not
rehabbing enough you're not rejuvenating
enough I mean if you are always go go go
go go but you're never taking a moment
to give your brain in your body that
break then you're never going to have
the level of energy that frankly you
deserve we know from science and
neuroscience you must be getting seven
to eight hours of sleep
distantly if you don't believe that
please go do the research it's unanimous
it's fifty years of sleep research now
your cognitive abilities go so much
further down in terms of negatives
negativity your ability to think your
ability to process when you're tired and
along with your cognition goes your
motivation you know it's just like if
you can't think you can't get really
motivated and excited about things so
please just get some rest in make sure
if you're not getting enough of sleep
then meditate or nap throughout the day
whenever you can find your spot I don't
care if that means you come home and
before you go in to hang out with the
kids you just pass out for 15 minutes in
the car you know just do something to
rejuvenate yourself because if you're
not rested the passion is going to go
away and you and I both know that we are
living a culture right now where
everyone's burning the candle at both
ends and most of what they're doing is
really necessary they're just replying
to everybody else and losing themselves
in their lives we got to get you back
and the way to get your energy back is
first and foremost please get some rest
passion is not a job a sport or a hobby
it is the full force of your attention
and energy that you give to whatever is
right in front of you and if you're so
busy looking for this passion you could
miss opportunities that change your life
you could also miss out on great love
because that's what happens when you
have tunnel vision trying to find the
one we all think we know the kind of
person we are and the kind of person we
could love but sometimes we're wrong
blissfully wrong and sometimes you know
what you're gonna do next right I mean I
don't I love not knowing what I'm going
to be doing five years from now or what
I'll be into and that's okay it's okay
not to know you know why because the
most fulfilling relationships the most
fulfilling careers are those that still
have the power to surprise you and as
for the things you know you want to do
you want to write a book you want to
start a business you want to change
careers great but if you're sitting
around waiting for passion to show up
and take you there you're going to be
waiting
long time so don't wait instead spend
your time and attention
solving your favorite problems look for
problems that need solving be useful
generous people will thank you and hug
you and pay you for it and that's where
passion is where your energy and effort
meets someone else's need that's when
you realize passion lives and realizing
you know what you have to contribute why
do you think when you ask people what
they're passionate about they say
helping other people so don't wait
listen to my mother just start doing
because to live a life full of meaning
and value you don't follow your passion
your passion follows you so I hope you
guys enjoyed my quick take on it is you
find your passion bikes warm you got to
explore explore explore and try
different things until you find the
thing that makes you come alive you're
not going to find your passion by just
sitting on the couch and watching TV all
day you got to get up and do things and
sometimes those things are unexpected
sometimes those things push your comfort
zone and at least try it once before you
give up on something
oh quick example that I told a couple
times in this channel but it's worth
repeating I'll say yes to doing
something once most of the time and as
an example I went rock climbing and I
hated it I'm afraid of heights it's not
a fear that I need to get over have a
desire to get over anytime soon I didn't
like how you know the strap was in my
crotch and I felt tight and anyway just
wasn't a pleasant experience for me so
when somebody asked me do I want to go I
said yes I'll go and try it out but I
didn't like it so I've never gone back
then I went snowboarding and I sucked at
the start and I failed and I got up and
fell and get up and fell and got up and
found would fall 30 times down the
mountain but I loved it and I fell in
love with it and I would push off
meetings and I would just cry to do as
much snowboarding as possible and I got
really good and for two winters I was
kind of obsessed with it and then it
slowly died off to where I was going you
know a couple times a year and this past
winter I didn't even go snowboarding at
all I just kind of lost the love and so
that can also happen when you explore
you find something that you get up
just with you you fall in love with it
but then that love fades until the
answer isn't to continue doing it it's
too when you stop loving something move
off and go do something else
the third examples I found salsa and I
found south of just by exploring again I
said yes to an opportunity they said yes
to going on trying to the class and I
fell in love with it something about the
music and the dancing the connection the
people I just fell in love with it it
made me come alive and now still ten
years later I'm still dancing I now own
uh salsa dancing school the largest may
be North America and that's my advice
for you is to explore things say yes to
things see what makes you come alive
sometimes you hate it at the start
sometimes you like it it's worth
exploiting a little bit more and then it
falls off and sometimes you find the
thing that you want to do for the next
decade Plus but you don't find it until
you say yes opportunities and you
explore explore explore until you find
the thing that makes you come alive so
I'd love to know what you think of this
video I'd love to know which clip
resonated the most with you and why
leave it down in the comments below I'm
going to join in discussion I made this
video because ty Darius Reed asked me to
so if there's a topic you'd like me to
cover on the next edition of believe
life leave in the comments below and
we'll sue we can do thank you again for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon